Thor love and thunder has goats a guy
called Gore two thores and Easter eggs
Galore did you spot the Watcher why is
that Fallen God so familiar keep
watching for all the small details you
may have missed warning spoilers ahead
Taiko otiti likes to give cameos to
trusted friends and actors whom he's
worked with before which often means
fellow new zealanders this time is
Jonathan bruff's turn Bruff was watiti's
co-star in the 2014 film version of what
we do in the shadows the vampire
documentary that's now a cult hit TV
series in Thor love it thunder Ruff
plays rappu the god that forsook Gore
and his people maybe we'll see jabane
Clement pop up in Thor 5.
while working out with some comically
enormous battle chains Thor wears a gray
undershirt and a trucker cap with a
graphic that reads the Avengers with the
names Thor Ant-Man Hulk and Iron Man in
red star bubbles overhead like a child
Thor has crossed out the three names
that aren't his plus the word the and he
scribbled the word strongest and Sharpie
so the Hat now says Thor strongest
Avenger this is a callback to a scene
from Thor Ragnarok when he tries to
restart the quinjet that Hulk crashed on
sakar in order to escape while trying to
use voice recognition software to unlock
the system he says Thor then Thor son of
Odin then God of Thunder to the computer
screen which buzzes as if the password
is incorrect each time finally he tries
this strongest Avenger access denied
strongest Avenger access denied
um you stalk of course once Hulk turns
back into Bruce Banner and engages with
the computer the computer system greets
him thusly welcome strongest Avenger uh
what apparently you Thor still hasn't
gotten over it it's a treat that the
Asgardian acting troop featuring Chris
Hemsworth's brother Lucas Thor Matt
Damon isloki and Sam Neil zoden is back
for Thor love and thunder but they
aren't the only famous actors treading
the boards this time around joining
Hemsworth Damon and Neil is Melissa
McCarthy portraying hella from Thor
Ragnarok while Ben Falcone McCarthy's
real-life husband and frequent creative
collaborator is directing the whole
thing and takes a bow with the actors at
the end
when the much anticipated teaser trailer
for Thor love and thunder finally
dropped one shot caught the attention of
fans who were well versed in Thor Comics
it was already known that the plot would
follow Thor's efforts to stop Gore the
god butcher from Exterminating the gods
himself included the storyline was
largely borrowed from the comic Thor God
of Thunder which began in 2012 and
quickly became a fan favorite in fact
the main changes are some omissions a
condensed timeline and some tweaks to
character designs Gore still becomes the
god butcher after his last child starves
he starts by killing a golden god and it
takes multiple thores to defeat him in
both the comics and the film falgar of
the Behemoth is one of his victims in
showing us what became a foligar which
heedi composed a shot that's nearly
identical to a panel from Thor God of
Thunder volume 3. the mountainous body
of the god of the galactic Frontier lies
on its side with mouth gaping and blood
trickling from nostrils it's Rocky icy
spikes pointing diagonally into the sky
Thor stands on the taller of the two
snow-covered monoliths distraught at the
death of his friend at the hands of Gore
who's still out there on his quest to
kill every last God the only difference
is the addition of Korg in the movie
version who isn't accompanying Thor on
this particular Adventure in the comics
the village of tonsburg has been a part
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe dating
all the way back to 2011's Thor when
Odin and the asgardians defended against
the frost Giants who want to take over
the nine Realms starting with this
Seaside Outpost in 965. after Asgard the
place not the people Falls in Thor
Ragnarok the Norse gods relocate to
tonsburg and rename it after their own
realm fast forward to about 2025 and new
Asgard is a Disney world-like tourist
destination with relics rides shows
souvenirs and cruise ships lining the
shore King Valkyrie and meek both
wearing smart business suits preside
over this booming economy what's really
interesting is that the use of tonsberg
as the mcu's new Asgard is evidence of
some excellent research tonesberg which
is a real place with about 32 000
residents is the oldest city in Norway
with deep connections to Viking history
if you visit you'll see two Viking ships
dating back back to the 9th century on
display in the harbor the port city was
a vital training Hub then and is a
modernized commercial center especially
for cheese and a tourist stop now no
word on whether there is a mjolnir
display though
in Thor love and thunder our hero
acquires his new pets as a traditional
gift of thanks after he drives off Alien
Invaders
those they are wonderful yes they are
they also scream quite a lot
super-sized screaming goats are exactly
the kind of nonsensical yet hysterical
flourish that you might expect from a
Taiko a TV film but these creatures
actually first appeared in Marvel Comics
in the 1960s and their mythological
Legacy dates back even further to the
1200s according to 2011's journey into
mystery number 623 Loki tricked his
brother into thinking that everyone
would be impressed if he could tame
goats instead of horses which earned the
God of Thunder ridicule instead of
respect but Thor and his horned trusty
seeds would have the last laugh the
goats named toothnasher and tooth
grinder were imbued with magic not only
can they easily pull their Master's
Chariot whether on land in the air
through space or to alternate Dimensions
they're also intensely loyal and can
communicate with Thor and they can be
resurrected by mjolnir the Thor of Norse
mythology has two mystical goats too
congressner and Anton yoster make their
debut in the poetic Edda in a tale
called Thor's journey to udgaard a poor
farmer bestows them upon him as they can
be eaten then resurrected so long as
their bones aren't broken delicious for
most of his nine appearances in the MCU
Chris Hemsworth's Thor has dressed in
darker colors or more casually than his
Comics counterpart from Thor to Avengers
Age of Ultron his costumes are like
muted versions of the 2007's Thor Comic
Book reboot and 2002's the ultimates but
the mcu's Thor spends a lot of time in
tank tops hoodies and leather vests
Marvel Studios has been particularly
hesitant to cover Hemsworth's flowing
blonde locks and close-up worthy face
he's rarely been outfitted with a
headpiece on film even though he
regularly wears one in print Thor love
and thunder puts Hemsworth through a
whole fashion Show's worth of costume
changes among them are some vintage
looks that fans have been waiting to see
brought to life on the big screen in the
Montage that plays his chord narrates a
teenage Thor wearing Jack Kirby's
original 1962 design can be seen running
through a sunlit forest complete with
Silver Wing tone later when Thor sees
Jane in her Mighty Thor accurate get up
he switches to more colorful red gold
and blue armor featuring a geometric
heavy duty helmet that obscures
everything except his eyes and mouth
Hemsworth doesn't keep it on for long
but this costume looks like a throwback
to 1998's Thor Vol 2 number 44 in which
the character adopts a new helmet that's
a combination of his own and Odin's when
it's his turn to rule as Odin is gone
and Thor is called to serve again it's
an appropriate Choice finding ways to
get superheroes in their comic book
costumes seems to be a running theme in
phase 4. early in the film Valkyrie
wears an oversized Phantom of the Opera
sweatshirt the popular Andrew Lloyd
Webber show which is the longest running
musical in history doesn't have any
obvious connections to Marvel or Norse
mythology this reference which is both
hard to miss and hard to interpret is
all about Tessa Thompson as the actors
often do Thompson imagined a rich
backstory for her character she reasoned
that while living amongst humans
Valkyrie would have taken an interest in
some of their hobbies and Thompson
decided that Valkyrie became a fan of
musical theater which she explained at
the Thor love and thunder Premiere she
loves musical theater which is why she's
wearing a Phantom of the Opera Fletcher
Thor Ragnarok brought a multitude of new
characters into the MCU including Korg
and meek Who provided some of the film's
best comic relief and quickly became fan
favorites the former has a much larger
role in Thor love and thunder where he's
become Thor's best friend as they
adventure with the Guardians of the
Galaxy while the latter has been serving
in King valkyrie's Administration korg's
personality and Physiology are fairly
easy to grasp he's an affable rock guy
while Meeks requires closer inspection
the character first appeared in The
Incredible Hulk vol 3 number 92. in the
comics Meek is a sakharan insectoid who
can metamorphose and who's enslaved
after his family is murdered the meek
that we meet in Thor Ragnarok is being
held captive by the Grand Master and
forced to fight in his Gladiator pits
his body's been retrofitted with a metal
exoskeleton that's given him blades for
hands but in Thor love and thunder Meeks
undergone quite the transformation the
purple insectoid is female now she wears
a skirt suit with a blouse with a bow at
the neck there's precedence for this in
the comics too at one point due to
exposure to chaos energy Meeks switches
genders and can lay eggs taika watidi
has also given her some new appendages
presumably for her duties as king
valkyrie's assistant her exoskeleton has
been updated with dry erase markers
which she uses to take notes during
Thor's speech oh God we're gonna die
when fans first caught a glimpse of Zeus
in the trailer for Thor love and thunder
most assumed he was ruling over Olympus
but that floating golden Paradise is
actually omnipotent City a billions of
years old Retreat for the gods that like
everything else in the movie has its
roots in Marvel Comics omnipotent city
is a better choice of setting for a
story about a villain who wants to kill
all gods and not just the Greek gods
This Is My Vow oh God shall die so it
makes sense that Thor and Zeus aren't
the only Immortals that Marvel has
brought into the MCU for a little screen
time many of these Gods can be spotted
in the background as Thor and his team
make their way to the city they very
wildly in size and appearance and since
most don't have speaking roles we can't
say for sure who exactly they're meant
to be but all of them do wear the
distinct costumes of their Heritage and
since Moon Knight recently brought World
culture-based Gods into the MCU it's
possible we'll see more of them in the
future
one of the Gods who does get a line of
dialogue is Dionysus played by Simon
Russell Beale omnipotent city is a den
of revelry pageantry debauchery and
little concern for the rest of the
universe soon 's mainly concerned with
bragging about how many followers he has
and planning the next orgy when the
camera pans down to the Greek delegation
who Faithfully support him over Thor we
see a man in a toga drinking out of a
chalice this is Dionysus the god of
theater sex and wine and Zeus's son
Dionysus is basically the patron saint
of letting loose and having a good time
he's associated with festivals that
celebrate the Harvest and fertility at
which people were known to get frisky
and very intoxicated he was so popular
in his own day and beyond that is the
Greek god most often depicted in art
in both Marvel Comics and the MCU Jane
Foster loses her mother to cancer at a
young age then becomes a victim of the
disease herself Thor love and thunder
relies upon context clues to tell this
tragic story but the print inspiration
provides more explanation in the comics
Jane is diagnosed with breast cancer
When mjolnir Calls her to become Mighty
Thor she feels healthy and strong but
its magic zaps her body of toxins
including the chemotherapy that was
targeting the cancer cells thus Gene's
cancer actually progresses faster each
time she picks up Thor's hammer until
she ultimately dies in the film her
Inner Circle Eric Selvig Darcy Thor
merely say that treatment isn't working
and they eventually figure out that
mjolnir isn't helping we know how the
hammer affected her condition and that
she waited too long to see doctors but
the movie tells us less about the cancer
itself while it's certainly possible
it's the result of genetic
predisposition position it's also
possible that it's related to her
exposure to The Ether in Thor of the
Dark World something is within her
father something I have not seen her
world has its heal as they call doctors
let them deal with it Jane became
infected with the reality Stone in its
liquid state and its immense energy
nearly killed her before Thor outsmarted
malekith into drawing it out of her in
the comics as in the film Jane is
welcomed into Valhalla the Marvel
Cinematic Universe started audiences off
easy with 2008's Iron Man starring
Robert Downey Jr which is about human
characters from our world 14 years later
MCU movies and TV shows have gotten
decidedly weirder from allocator Loki to
zombie strange our generally accepted
rules about time space and the nature of
life itself no longer apply characters
who can be kind of difficult to wrap
your head around either are or are soon
to be part of the overarching narrative
and they all sort of have cameos and
Thor love and thunder celestials
technically make their debut in
Guardians of the Galaxy but we got to
know them better and see them in their
true form in eternals two celestials
guard the gate 2 of nipton city and once
head crashes down after a fight as far
as the other all-powerful but hard to
describe and disco some interesting
statuary busts line the cavernous room
that leads to eternity's gate one looks
suspiciously like the living tributyl
the cosmic embodiment of impartial
judgment another resembles the Watcher
who appeared in the animated series what
if voiced by Jeffrey Wright a being who
observes everything that happens in the
Multiverse but never interferes it's
probably more than just a coincidence
that production designers adorned the
set but these enormous bronze heads
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
the Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the Bell so you don't miss a
single one
foreign